90 of blood pressure is called essential
hypertension and they don't even know
what causes it after all of this
research today I'm going to unravel
blood pressure and give you some natural
solutions that may have a lot less side
effects than medication of course check
with your doctor before implementing any
of these Solutions so you have about a
hundred thousand miles
of blood vessels in your body well that
is a lot of blood vessels and these
blood vessels do go to many locations in
your body many organs in fact all of
your organs receive blood from your
vascular system and so the problems of
blood pressure extend Way Beyond just
the vascular system Way Beyond just your
heart it can affect the brain it can
affect your eye it can affect the kidney
increasing your risk of getting heart
attacks and it definitely increases your
risk of getting a stroke by a factor of
3x and blood pressure problems are very
common if you're over 60 you have a 50
chance of getting hypertension to me
that is just way way too high now
hypertension can also be compensating
for various things for example if you
have hypoxia let's say in your lungs you
have COPD you have a lung problem where
you don't have enough oxygen the body is
going to automatically sense that and
start increasing blood pressure to get
more blood in the area to get more
oxygen low oxygen situation in another
place so when someone then takes
medication to lower the blood pressure
what happens to the lungs right it
already is not getting enough oxygen now
it's really not going to get enough
oxygen so this is one reason why people
don't really feel good many times when
they get on blood pressure medication
especially in the brain because it
creates other issues I mean I think a
really important question would be to
understand why you have high blood
pressure in the first place and this is
just not emphasized very well it's more
like well you have this disease we don't
really know what it is take this
medication for a while you know drink
more water get more exercise
etc etc from my viewpoint there's
several common reasons for blood
pressure low potassium
low magnesium
and low vitamin D levels so if I had
hypertension those would be three things
that I would look at immediately but
instead in the medical profession you're
told to restrict sodium that is the
primary focus not to increase potassium
to reduce sodium and if that doesn't
work then the next thing to do is to
give you a water pill a diuretic
primarily they use a common one called
Hydrochlorothiazide this is a diuretic
it gets rid of fluid and the sodium in
the fluid but it is also
a silent depletor of potassium so now we
end up with lower amounts of potassium
and a potassium deficiency could be the
reason why you have high blood pressure
in the first place now we go from low
potassium to extremely low potassium so
therefore this can be more beneath for
medication and of course when we talk
about potassium they may recommend
potassium but unfortunately potassium
only comes in 99 milligram pills or less
and the requirement for potassium is
quite high it's like 4 700 milligrams
and you have these pills that are 99
milligrams
okay how many times this 99 or let's
just round it off to 100 go into
4700 okay you do the math you'd have to
have a lot of pills but this diuretic
also depletes
magnesium the other common reason why
people have high blood pressure another
side effect of this diuretic is the
increase of homocysteine now if that
doesn't work there's always the calcium
channel blockers okay those are
medications for high blood pressure as
well just working from a different angle
the problem is it has some slight minor
complications if you take it chronically
over five years it can have a tendency
to shrink your brain it also tends to
increase your risk of certain types of
cancer and in one study as far as the
effectiveness goes they compared it
against other medications that lower
blood pressure and it really only
brought your blood pressure down by 0.1
that's only like one tenth of one point
okay so to me that's pretty
insignificant then you have other
medications like the ACE inhibitors the
problem is with that one it does
increase the risk of getting allergies
or even being allergic to the medication
significantly also it can create a
chronic cough as a side effect now I'm
not sure if you got the recent memo
about aspirin they finally found out
that it doesn't really give you
um many good benefits the outcomes are
not that great and this was in Jama
aspirin myocardial infarction study
research group they found that the
aspirin a day has no benefit now there
was another study that rekindled
recommending aspirin taking an aspirin a
day but they didn't even use aspirin
they used bufferin okay which is a
different type of medication and that
had magnesium oxide okay magnesium
actually helps lower blood pressure and
they also had added some beta-carotene
so who knows what was causing what
there's something else that you should
know about it's called nitric oxide
nitric oxide greatly supports
the inner layer of the arteries okay it
helps to lower blood pressure because
it's a vasodilator some people even try
to increase it to handle their erectile
dysfunction because that's a vascular
problem you see we're so focused on the
arteries but it can affect a lot of
things you've probably heard of even
vascular dementia because of what it can
do to the brain we have an enzyme that
helps make nitric oxide okay and that
enzyme can be inhibited or turned off to
a certain degree by a genetic variation
problem so if you have this problem you
might not have the benefit of that
enzyme to make nitric oxide thereby
developing hypertension and you can get
a test to evaluate if you have this
problem there's a couple ways to do it
you can look at a DNA test or even get
this other test it's called adma and
that stands for asymmetrical dimethyl
Arginine so getting a test will tell you
very quickly if you're making enough of
this nitric oxide now the solution that
I would recommend that has very minimal
side effects if any is just to go out
and buy some L-Arginine L-Arginine will
help you make more nitric oxide so you
can just include that as your protocol
for helping yourself with this high
blood pressure situation another really
good natural remedy for high blood
pressure is garlic garlic can act as a
natural ACE inhibitor as well as
increasing this nitric oxide another
really good food to take if you have
high blood pressure is celery celery has
a couple powerful phytonutrients that
can help lower blood pressure and reduce
adrenaline so it helps you sleep it
helps your blood pressure you'd want to
take like four stalks of the celery
maybe with your last meal of the day and
you'll find that you'll actually get
some benefit from that now to support
the endothelial layer of your arteries
tocotrinos is one of the best remedies
for that that's the type of vitamin E so
when you think about anything
um damaging the inside of the artery
think tocatrinos and tocatrinos are
really good for Angina heart problems
but especially to help act as a powerful
antioxidant for the inside layer of your
arteries let's summarize everything so
we have potassium magnesium where can
you get that
from salads okay larger amounts of
salads on a regular basis you can also
get these in electrolyte powder as well
vitamin D3 you can get that from the sun
it's very hard in the winter so start
taking vitamin D3 that might just handle
your blood pressure but you need to take
at least 20 000 IUS every single day
start including garlic in the diet
celery and don't forget about the
L-Arginine okay you can get in a powder
and maybe take a half a scoop or even a
whole scoop each day okay to help
increase nitric oxide and those
tocotrenals that might come in handy to
support the inside layer of your
arteries but realize that you also need
to handle the foundational problem of
your diet and for information on that I
put that video up right here check it
out